there's a lot of reasons it's a I mean I
think it's a momentous shift in American
history and it and it's really a
divergent with a place where the US has
diverged from Europe and other
industrial democracies you know
incarceration rates and most democracies
are pretty stable and were for most of
American history but starting in the
late 1960s the u.s. changed course
pretty radically in incarceration rates
quintupled over the last third of the
20th century you know conventional
wisdom is that it must have something to
do with crime it turns out it doesn't
crime rates fluctuate pretty much
independent of or largely independent of
incarceration rates and what I argue in
the book is that it really has to do
with politics and in particular has to
do with racial politics
what I'm arguing is like the big
causative shift has to do with the
backlash against civil rights and and
the kind of southern strategy and the
way Democrats have tried to protect the
right flank by throwing criminal
defendants to the Wolves in a sense but
there's all sorts of legislative
initiatives that have gone through that
have made that happen and certainly
Sentencing Guidelines have had the
unintended consequence of shifting
discretionary shifting discretion from
judges to prosecutors because almost all
cases are dealt with in plea bargains
and it's meant that the real decision on
how much time someone's going to do
takes place at filing rather than in a
courtroom and even more than that
mandatory minimums but there's all sorts
of you know every legislative session
over the from the 1970s forward has had
in every state almost and in the federal
government have had different kind of
faux sigh and different slogans
zero-tolerance mandatory minimums three
strikes all of them have converged to
build the largest prison system in the
world
they have some I mean my own sense isn't
not as much as some critics of the
so-called prison industrial complex
think you know Texas locks up more
people in private prisons than anywhere
else there's 20,000 of them my own state
now where I'm living in Hawaii ships a
huge part of its population to private
prisons on the mainland in this desert
president Arizona and it's mostly
indigenous Hawaiians there who are
bearing the brunt of the drug war and
the kind of war on crime and those
private prison companies are skilled
lobbyists they often hire former
bureaucrats former legislators former
lieutenant governor's to make their case
and I think in some cases they have in
some many cases they have argued for
longer sentences and tougher law
enforcement as a way to generate demand
for their services but I don't think you
can show and they've done that
successfully so so some some small
extent of breathtaking prison growth in
America can probably be attributed to
the profit motive there's even more
money to be made in you know
construction contracts for new prisons
but there's a whole lot of ways that
private industry can feed at the trough
of government and I don't know that
prison lobbyists are any more effective
than you know road contractors or even
people who could build community
colleges if government were going in a
different direction and also some states
have had very high rates of prison
growth California for instance with no
private prison industry because the
guard Union there is so powerful and so
effective that they are well paid
compared to corrections officers across
the rest of the country and they have
thus far that we'll see what happens in
the next few months been able to avoid
much privatization
you